CHRIS YING: My
name is Chris Ying.
I'm the editor-in-chief
of a magazine called
Lucky Peach I
always forget when I
come to do these
that I'm supposed
to introduce the person.
And in this case, I'm
introducing myself to you
for the first time.
I've never met Chef.
JOSE ANDRES: How are you, man?
CHRIS YING: But it is a great
honor for someone like me--
a tremendous privilege to get
to sit here and talk to you.
I think that, as evidenced
by how many cooks I
see in here in chef's coats--
and people who have come up
here to take photos with
you, people who are in the
know in the food world really,
really, admire and respect you,
and I am among those.
Jose Andres is
the chef and owner
of the Think Food
Group, which includes
innumerable restaurants
across the United States,
in Miami, Los Angeles,
DC-- places like Minibar
in Jaleo and now Beef Steak,
which we'll talk about today.
But when you started
cooking, Chef,
did you intend to be
speaking someday at a tech
campus in Mountain View?
Is that why you set out cooking?
JOSE ANDRES: This is
a good place to be.
I've been here
already a few times.
I came as a
translator and nobody
could understand anything.
So now, finally, they
invite me as a speaker.
And look, 50 people showed
up, so, that's great.
But yeah, it feels good.
I don't know about
you guys, but I'm 45,
and I Iook so old already
with three daughters.
I look at myself in the
mirror and you wonder.
But since I was very
young, I knew very clear
that I wanted to be a cook.
My father and my mother very
much planted the seed of that.
Helping my father making
Sunday paellas for anybody
that would show up in
the middle of the forest
and helping my father gather
the wood, and helping my father
make the fire.
I fell in love with
making the fire.
Until one day I told my dad,
why don't you let me cook?
He said, no, I need
you to do the fire.
Yeah, but I know how
to make the fire.
Make somebody else
make the fire.
I want to cook.
No, I need you to do the fire.
Paella and fire, hand by hand.
If you don't have
the right fire,
it will never be a right paella.
One day, he got very upset,
very upset, a big tantrum.
He sent me to the forest,
"Go to the forest."
When we finished,
he came and said,
"My son, I know you were
upset because I'm not
letting you cook and
you think that cooking
is the most important part.
But, actually, I gave you
the most important task.
That was making the fire.
If you control the fire,
then and only then one day,
you'll be able to cook."
Since then, I've
been always trying
to search what really
is my fire, what really
is what holds everything else.
The cooking is the obvious.
When we are able to achieve
success in the non-obvious
is when things begin moving.
So sorry for this
answer to your question.
CHRIS YING: Don't apologize.
It was poetic.
It was beautiful.
It's interesting you
bring up your upbringing.
I tend to believe that
environment, whether it's
social, cultural, or
literal environment,
has a lot to do with creativity.
And you are a Spanish chef.
You worked at El Bulli, and so
many great, innovative cooks
have come out of El Bulli--
out of Spain specifically.
Is there something about
the Spanish culture,
about the Spanish culinary
world that produces
innovative cooks like you?
JOSE ANDRES: It's very
funny because there
is this list called
the 50 best, which
is the biggest
gimmick of marketing
in the history of marketing.
But I'm telling you this, and I
would love to be in that list.
So on one side, I tell you it's
a big gimmick and marketing
thing.
On the other side, I'll
tell you I'm working hard
to be one day on that list.
But Ferran Adria was number one
for many years, rightfully so.
And now, for three years
already, Joan Roca, number one,
again.
It's funny because when I was
16, Joan Roca, who has just
been named the best
chef in the world,
he worked in my station one
month with me as my assistant.
He was five, six
years older than me.
And I really loved that man.
He's from Girona, one
hour away from El Bulli,
one hour away from Cadaques.
Cadaques is the land where
Dali, the great painter
had his house.
And he was nuts like a clown.
You can only paint what
he painted and be nuts.
Well, the great
Dali right there.
I don't know if he's the
wind, but out of that area
has been a lot of creativity.
And this will be funny to
study how the environment can
create creative minds.
Ferran Adria, as much
as you say today there's
many great chefs in the
world, the last revolution
we've seen in the last
15 years, 20 years only
happened because we had
two great minds born
in the same family with
the same last name, Ferran
Adria and Albert Adria.
And everybody has benefited
from it-- everybody.
We give them some
kind of-- some people
may say he's the best
chef in the world,
but it's not obvious.
We will only see how obvious
it is 100 years from now.
But Ferran Adria and El
Bulli single-handedly,
they inspire everybody around
them, I mean the Spanish chefs.
Spain was the first country
having conferences, where we
all shared everything we knew.
If I'm working with MIT now
on water surface tension,
and I'm training
five new dishes only
on the standing principles
of water surface tension.
And we're able to
develop a flour that
is able to grab
water, I will go on,
I will share this
with all my friends.
If the chefs of
Spain were the CEOs
of every pharmaceutical
industry in the world,
today will be zero
sickness in the world.
That's how big creativity
has been in Spain.
Before Ferran there were others,
but Ferran single-handedly
is the person that
was like Google.
Single-handedly
ignited a revolution
in culinary thinking that
is going beyond cooking.
I'm very happy that I was part
of that Big Bang that exploded
and I was there.
I saw the star explode.
I saw Ferran get
a piece of gelatin
in my station-- I had the
fryer-- almond gelatin.
And I was frying-- I had the
almond gelatin for one dish
and I was frying
artichoke chips.
And I could see that he
was looking at the gelatin
and looking at the hot oil.
And I said, I cannot believe
this guy will not do it.
He got the hot gelatin
and put it in the hot oil.
Common sense, what
it will tell you?
If you Google it,
water, hot oil,
it will tell you don't do it.
Oil is hydrophobic.
Actually it's royalty.
It doesn't like to be
mixed with water, which
is the poor, lowly people.
Well, he did it,
and it exploded.
But he knew it was going
to explode, by maybe not.
Nonetheless, many years
later, that gelatin of almond
looks like milk gelatin.
It looks like the beschamel that
in Spain we make croquettas,
the fried croquettes.
Eight years later, Ferran
created the liquid croquette.
You see?
That's what happened there
for a very strange reason.
He was not prepared.
He did not study.
He was at his washer.
You can barely
understand when he
talks because he's
thinking so much
quicker that his
words don't make it
into his tongue
to really deliver
what he's trying to tell you.
He doesn't care.
He's happy with himself.
He knows where he's going.
And if you try to follow,
he'll be happy you come.
But something happened
in Spain, and we should
be investigating what it is.
I don't know if it's a
spore from a mushroom.
I don't know, but
it's very funny
to understand that it's
an environment that
created a lot of creative people
in the shortest span of time
that we connect.
When I bring new people to
my creative team-- like,
that's not a good example, but
I read that Saddam Hussein only
covered himself with
people from his town.
So myself, I feel very protected
bringing people from my town,
because the moment
I bring them, I
don't need to tell
them anything.
But if I show them a
squash blossom and I say,
you know what we should do?
I don't have to say anything
else after the question mark.
Everybody's going to
get the squash blossom
and is going to start
working, and we're
going to come up with a lot of
things with the squash blossom.
And this is something
like this in the air that
is non-tangible.
It's intangible.
And it's very fascinating
when the click happens.
I guess all of you
Googlers of the world,
you are the same kind
of DNA, rare species.
That's how you all come
here, and everybody
works on different things,
but it's like a common.
In my world, I try
to bring people
that we kind of were
touched by the same spores
and same strange things
that are in the air, water,
and soil of Catalonia
and that part of Spain.
CHRIS YING: We've only
just met for as long
as we've been sitting
here, but I already
appreciate that you've
said 50 Best is a gimmick.
You've mentioned Albert
Adria in the same breath
as Ferran, which people
always forget about.
And you're into Saddam
Hussein as an inspiration.
So these are all
powerful things to me.
JOSE ANDRES: But things
can also show good.
CHRIS YING: Sure.
JOSE ANDRES: Shit.
I see the title.
CHRIS YING: I think
it's interesting.
I wanted to stay on this
on this idea of environment
and creativity a
little bit longer.
I always think it's really
appropriate and interesting
that so many innovative
tech companies are based
in Nortthern California
in the Bay Area,
not in, say, Los
Angeles or New York.
And I really tend to believe--
JOSE ANDRES: Or Washington, DC.
CHRIS YING: Or Washington, DC.
I think that it has to do with
whatever spores are in the air
here.
I really think that.
You are a decidedly
Spanish chef.
Your background is in Spain,
but your empire is in America.
And so what is it about
America in general
that is suitable or fertile
ground for your type of cooking
or your restaurants?
JOSE ANDRES: I have-- I
mean, I don't have an empire.
I have 21 restaurants.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS YING: I have none.
JOSE ANDRES: But my dream is
one day to have a unicorn.
I want to be worth
$1 billion very soon.
Right now, I think my company's
worth-- some stupid partners
of mine pay for 30%.
So technically, my company
is worth $25, $30 million,
which is kind of funny because
I came with $40 to America.
So it's a good start.
But then you see that some other
companies are worth $1 billion.
I'm like, what the fuck?
I'm only worth $40 and it
took me all these years.
So I'm trying to speed that up.
So [INAUDIBLE] America, I
was in the Spanish navy.
I was the cook of the admiral
and I was like, really?
I saw when I was little
in the port of Barcelona
with my father a ship called
Juan Sebastian Elcano.
It's a midshipman-training
ship for the Spanish navy.
And I told my dad, what do I
have to do to go on that boat?
Once you are old enough,
you will join the Navy.
And then, if you're lucky,
you'll go on that boat.
Many years later, I was lucky.
I always look at the stars.
I say, please, and
then things happen.
I go into the Navy.
They don't put me in the ship
or give me the opportunity
to choose a ship.
They put me to cook
for the admiral.
Are you kidding?
I'm coming from working
summer after summer
for 16 hours a day.
I can go to see the world,
and they're putting me
in the house of the admiral?
It was like "Desperate
Housewives" of the Navy.
They [INAUDIBLE] with their
wives, which they are adorable,
but you know what I mean.
And finally, I went and
I knocked on the door
and I told the admiral--
if you knock on the door,
things happen, right?
Like when you put any
word in your thing.
Things happen.
I begin looking for something,
and I end somewhere else.
It's magnificent.
It's a very powerful thing,
if you think about it.
Me, most of the time when I put
the word, I end somewhere else.
Like right now, I'm
trying to tell him
what's happening in America,
and I'm going back to Spain
30 years ago.
But there's an end to this.
So finally, he
grants me permission.
His wife is screaming.
They had to bring
her against the door
because she didn't
want me to leave.
Don't go, Jose.
But I go on the ship.
I come to America.
I arrived to Pensacola.
One of the flags there, they
celebrate the five flags,
is the Spanish flag.
I'm like, shit, I belong here.
I knew it.
I arrived in New York.
I finished my Navy, and I'm
like, where do I want to be?
I wanted to be in America.
Why?
Because I could sense
that one guy could
be on Fifth Avenue with an
ugly, smelly, dirty hot dog
stand and be his own
king in his own kingdom.
And if you can
succeed in selling
hot dogs in an ugly cart, with
hot dogs that you don't know
how many bacterias
they have around them--
but then nothing happens
because technology
is making those hot dogs.
It used to be believable.
You can leave them in
the street for a year
and nothing happens
to the hot dog.
That simple thing of seeing
that so many people who
were non-Americans--
you will go to Queens,
you will go to Little Columbia
and there would be the arepa
stand.
So, shit, there's
things happening here.
So me coming to America
became the biggest university
of my life.
I left school when I was 14,
15, and my life university
has been being around places
that really motivate me.
So for me, coming to New
York was a life experience.
And I wish I knew 25 years
ago what I know today,
business-wise.
Because once you understand
the business side, any dreams
and creativity you have, you
can make it happen on your own.
You don't need anybody else.
So that's-- I fell in love
with America and the dream that
anything's possible.
I repeat this all the time.
Winston Churchill, he's one of
my most inspirational phrases
that I ever heard,
that success is
going from failure to failure
without losing enthusiasm.
And if you apply this
to your life, shit.
Life is great.
You are trying to
make an omelette,
and you go up in the
air, and it breaks down.
Shit, change the
name of the dish,
scrambled eggs with potatoes.
Simple.
But you can apply this
to more serious things.
And I learned that when you keep
changing the name of the dish,
amazing things
happen to your life.
If you keep complaining
that your omelette broke,
nothing will happen.
If you all of a sudden
change the name of dish,
all of a sudden, you
create something else.
Every time you
flip the omelette,
take the pan out and
out let it break.
It's big fucking creativity.
Imagine when we apply the same
things to very serious things.
Amazing things will happen.
CHRIS YING: It's
always so interesting
to hear someone in
your position talk
about things like that because
Americans, we romanticize
Spain, Italy, Japan, and
Turkey as these amazing places
to eat at and go,
and we never think we
have anything like that here.
But there's something romantic
about Americans' food culture
as well.
I want to talk a little bit
about innovation and Minibar
and creativity.
And Minibar, your
restaurant in DC,
strikes me as the most difficult
kind of restaurant to have.
It's so intensely experiential.
It's not just come in,
sit down, eat, leave.
And there's so much going on.
People come into your
restaurant expecting something
they've never seen before.
And in the wrong hands, those
are the worst restaurants
that you can possibly go
to if somebody doesn't
know what they're doing.
So talk to me
about your process.
And obviously, so
much of it has to do
with your experience
and the fact
that you know what
the fuck you're doing.
But how often do you
have to edit yourself?
Where do these ideas come from?
How do you push without pushing
too far and losing people?
JOSE ANDRES: First, I
try not to lose myself,
and then when I achieve
that-- first it's
understanding the team.
If you are one brain
and one person alone,
it's very difficult,
especially today.
I think we have so
much information.
In part, you are
the problem of there
being so much information.
But then when you
are able to focus,
really, amazing
things will happen.
So in the old days, cooks,
we would go to the market.
We would buy our
carrots and our chicken.
We'd come to the
kitchen and we'd
repeat the traditional
dishes of the past.
That's what we've always done.
All of a sudden, you move
away from your comfort zone.
I guess everyone
of you sometimes,
you'll have to move
from your comfort zone.
If you're surrounded
by the same people
from the same
expertise as you, it's
one moment that you
become part of this circle
that then nothing else comes.
It's good that you
are able to-- like
it was a comet that
came from another galaxy
and is the one that got the
first cells of life to Earth.
This is the same in creativity.
You need to be impacted by
others to keep creating life.
And if you're not
impacted by others,
you have to become a meteor on
your own or comet on your own
and leave and try to crash
against another planet
in another galaxy.
And things will happen.
That's what I've always
been trying to do.
Still, I go to the markets.
Like, put on the video.
But I go to the
markets and I do this.
Put on the video of the market.
[INAUDIBLE] today, yeah?
Oh my god.
And then I go to the market.
No, the market.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSE ANDRES: Quick.
So I go to the market.
But I'm tired of buying.
This is actually a terrible
example of creativity
because nothing
happened out of that.
The only good thing
is on the worst
day of the market, the
coldest day of the market,
with the least amount of
vegetables in the market,
we were able to bring
life to the market.
So I got these 120 kids from
Astoria, my home region,
who for some strange
reason, they adore me.
And they came driving all night
to be in Washington with me,
because I told them,
if you come to DC,
I'll invite you to lunch.
Shit.
They came six hours driving.
And once I'm there,
what do I do with them?
They had their instruments.
It's very unorganized.
I took them to the market,
and I got all my chefs,
and we got pans and pots.
We began making noise, but
noise began getting a rhythm.
And rhythm, by
[INAUDIBLE], becomes
being surrounded by instruments.
Some of them are
local musicians.
And all of a sudden,
violin will start playing.
Cello will start playing,
trumpets, people clapping.
All of a sudden, the
everyday market that you go
becomes something else.
That's what I tried
to do every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, said that, I try
to go to Seattle,
and I knock on the
door of Dale Chihuly.
What the fuck you want?
I say, I want to work with you.
And I create an entire
series of dishes
inspired of Dale Chihuly.
Or I go to MIT, which
I don't understand
a word those guys are trying to
tell me, but I look very smart.
And because now for
some weird reason
I've been teaching
at Harvard, everybody
believes that when
you are in a room,
you know what they're talking
about, which is fascinating,
right?
Like because you know, Jose,
what we're talking about.
I say, sure, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I know.
I know this question
of energy, sure.
And this is what happens.
I began going away
from my comfort zone
every single time,
every time I can.
And you begin learning.
And when you talk about
meat, now it's not meat.
It's pH.
What is the pH of meat
when they kill meat?
What is your pH?
You have no clue.
You have to Google it.
And probably the
information will be wrong
because there's so many
places to get the information.
So I began going to places.
You move away of
your comfort zone,
life changes in amazing ways.
You want to see a video?
Would you like to see a video of
my mother's cheese and almond,
transformed by me, or a
spring garden inspired
on Dale Chihuly?
AUDIENCE: Both.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSE ANDRES: What kind
of people are you?
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS YING: Let's
see your mother's--
JOSE ANDRES: I mean,
I ask you a question
and you answer me back.
Give me a break.
CHRIS YING: Let's see
your mother's dish.
JOSE ANDRES: Huh?
CHRIS YING: Let's see
your mother's dish.
JOSE ANDRES: OK, two ingredients
only, almonds and cheese.
You know what I'm talking about?
Are you understanding English?
[LAUGHTER]
So this is my mother's almonds
and cheese, a very traditional
tapas what I'm about to do.
We fry almonds.
Who can fry almonds?
Everybody can fry almonds.
We fry almonds, Marcona almonds,
the best almonds in the world.
Now, California is under
fire because you guys
are ending the
water in California
because you produce
so much almonds.
Give me a break.
Almonds, water, we blend it.
This is a very high tech dish.
We are making like
almond butter, right?
We put it on a Paco
Jet, and that machine
allows us to get even
a thinner butter, OK?
You see how cute?
Mm.
Wow.
That's the best almond
butter in the world.
You'd have to be peanuts to
have peanut butter once you
taste this.
Then we had add cream,
and we blend further.
And now what we've done, we
changed the form of the almond.
Why we did that?
Because the almond
tells me, Jose,
I am tired to look
like my other almonds.
I want to be different.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to be
different for my life.
I'm tired of looking
like an almond.
I don't want to be recognized.
CHRIS YING: It's like
Bruce Jenner of almonds.
JOSE ANDRES: Yup.
[LAUGHTER]
We use liquid nitrogen, that
now every single food created,
finger points.
Not too long ago, oh,
this chef is not natural.
He's using liquid nitrogen.
Shit, we can use a microwave
and it's OK.
And take a look what happens.
The almond is being changed.
Now it's frozen.
And it's frozen, and the form
has been changed completely.
Now the almond becomes
something like you can hold
that dreams of anything else.
And that is the dream of cheese.
Look at what happens
when it melts.
It goes back to
its natural state.
But by applying temperature
and changing its form,
we were able to change an
almond in whatever we wanted.
And the cheese tells
me, I'm tired of being
eaten the same way.
Change me.
And we are changing it further.
And we are making this mousse.
You see nitro oxide, which is
an amazing, amazing technique.
And there, we are able
to put the lightest
mousse in the history of your
life, a touch of passionfruit,
a little bit of the
almond, Marcona, grated.
And those are the
cheese and almonds
that my mother
serves to everybody.
So did I answer?
CHRIS YING: Yes.
You know, so often
people look at-- when you
see that, you understand it.
You understand
where it came from,
why each technique happened.
There's no excess move there.
You're doing what it calls for.
So often, modernist cooking,
avant-garde cooking,
whatever you want to call
it, gets sort of identified
as like a fringe thing.
It's like a crazy thing.
It's a fringe thing.
But those techniques end up
trickling down all the time.
And every new cooking
technique was weird and off
at some point.
JOSE ANDRES: Agree.
CHRIS YING: You've been
doing this for a while now.
Have you seen things that were
once crazy, avant-garde bleed
into normal, like
what everybody eats?
JOSE ANDRES: At Starbucks when
you ask for the cappuccino--
I read that they took the
cappuccino out of the menu?
What they were thinking?
Did the CEO press the
wrong Send button?
[LAUGHTER]
They took cappuccino
out of every Starbucks?
I didn't know that.
I found out on
Google this morning.
I mean it.
I mean it, very recent.
If you go, you'll see they have
these bottles, the same bottle.
And they make whipped cream.
But this is going to be
revolutionizing the world even
further, because I don't
think we began using them yet
to its full potential.
But you can make mousses that
they are butterless, creamless.
We can make a mousse out of
water-- a mousse out of water,
tasty and amazing.
So this is a simple,
amazing revolution
that is going to trickle
down for years to come.
And food doesn't go
to waste, because you
can conserve, thanks to
the CO2 if you are using it
for soda, other types.
Or the nitro oxide,
you can keep it
for weeks, two weeks,
three weeks, four weeks.
And it doesn't go bad.
So it's a good, good revolution.
But one of the revolutions, for
example, is over 200 years old
and I'm so sad we
are not using it
to feed 1.x billion people
in the world that are hungry,
would be canning.
If you Google it, and
you put "canning,"
you're going to see one guy
shows up, Nicolas Appert.
Initially, this was
invented in 1810.
This was invented because
Napoleon Bonaparte needed a way
to feed the troops.
And he was right.
He lost the campaign of
Russia because he lacked food.
He was giving 10,000
francs to anybody
who will come up with a system.
Nicolas Appert came up with
a method called Apperture
and was the invention
of canning, 1809,
printed the book in 1810.
I'm very proud of
this because I own
one of the original
works signed by him.
That was a counterfeiting thing.
He didn't sign
because he was famous.
It was the way to say,
this is my invention.
And I hold this in high esteem.
I wish that today
in third world,
we would be using
canning to preserve
the goodness of the Earth.
I'm not an expert around the
world, but Haiti I know well.
Cambodia I know well.
And our culture goes
to waste because they
don't have a way to preserve
the foods most of the time.
And thus I began wondering,
how did we make that happen?
Why is canning
not something like
that's more available to
that part of the world?
We were able to start preserving
the goodness of the Earth.
At the very least,
they don't have
to be spending more
energy than they receive
to try to keep
searching for food,
that this is what's happening.
The poor of the world,
it's a very simple equation
of more energy spent in
trying to feed themselves
than the food they're
able to feed themselves.
So they are negative in
the calorie equation.
If we are able to change
the calorie equation, all
of a sudden, there would not
be poor people in the world.
And the world will be richer
because more people with money
and non-poor means the world
should be doing better.
So imagine how technology
can be changing
the lives of the
many by only changing
the imbalance of
calorie-- simple equation,
simple algorithm that you
will have to adapt depending
what part of the world you are.
Because if you are
in the North Pole,
you will need more calories
than if you are-- you know,
because it's colder, whatever.
But anyway, I don't know why
I was giving you this answer,
but I thought it
was a cool answer.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS YING: The
next way you want
to try to revolutionize
the world is
even older than canning.
You want people to
eat more vegetables.
And I've read you
talking about things,
and I agree
wholeheartedly about this.
I love meat.
But meat is a little bit boring.
There's only so many things
you can do with meat.
And so what is it about
vegetables that excites you
as an eater and as a cook?
You're standing up already.
JOSE ANDRES: I'm going to
give you a round answer.
CHRIS YING: Yeah, here we go.
JOSE ANDRES: So you ask
me about vegetables?
CHRIS YING: Yeah.
JOSE ANDRES: Who has seen
"Hannibal," Hannibal Lecter?
Do you know my participation
on that series?
All the food you see is mine.
[LAUGHTER]
It's actually a great
woman, Janice Poon.
She's the food stylist.
She's the nicest,
paints, everything.
So I've been behind
not only of the food,
but some of the conversations
through the series,
I've been in charge
of helping create
who was Hannibal the foodie.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, it's very sad that this
will be on my RIP, R-I-P.
"He made Hannibal a foodie."
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I know.
I know it's scary this happens.
You don't believe me?
Take a look at this.
You don't have it?
What?
It's not online?
CHRIS YING: I feel like
somebody in this room
should be able to
fix this, Randy.
This seems crazy.
JOSE ANDRES: Can
you Yahoo something?
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSE ANDRES: Hey!
CHRIS YING: Provocateur.
JOSE ANDRES: Yeah, but
it's a pain in the butt.
In my iPad, some
things keep changing.
What the heck?
It changes, the searcher.
I have to go back
to [INAUDIBLE].
I have a bug or something there.
How you call it?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
--[INAUDIBLE] Still love your
little rare treats, don't you,
Hannibal?
The more expensive and difficult
they are to obtain, the better.
-It's a distinction that
adds some expectations.
JOSE ANDRES: I put that
ham in the series, people!
[LAUGHTER]
I put the ham.
I created that script moment.
Why I did it?
A. I'm a killer for
anything in Spanish.
Yeah, stop it.
Out.
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
And I am the
importer of iberico.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no, I am.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Not always.
JOSE ANDRES: Stop it.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRIS YING: Not always.
[LAUGHTER]
JOSE ANDRES: And
with my partner,
we convinced the USDA to
give us the first approved
slaughterhouse in
Spain-- no bribing.
It was legal.
I don't bribe.
[LAUGHTER]
I fed them good food.
But that's no equal bribing.
[LAUGHTER]
We did it by the book.
So I have a personal interest in
business, on bringing the ham.
But I have more than
business interest.
I have a personal
love-my-country business.
Imagine Mario Batali
with the white truffles
from Alba and Parmesan.
Fuck Italian cooking
without those things.
But if they have truffles and
Parmesan, give me a break.
You put Parmesan,
it's a good dish.
And I am a Spanish chef.
We have iberico.
So for me, when I was able to
put this Spanish thing there,
I was so like,
here we are, right?
What this has to do with
meat-- with vegetables?
[LAUGHTER]
That's a very
interesting question.
[LAUGHTER]
Really today, and
I do believe it
has to do with our DNA
and thousands of years
of evolution, that we are
human in one part of our body.
But another part of our
brain is totally controlled
by our animal behavior.
And our animal
behavior, it seems,
is highly attracted
to pure meat.
And I believe there's a
cannibal in every one of us.
We are highly attracted
to meat, to fat, obviously
to sugar and all those things.
But we are highly
attracted to meat.
We will eat a steak of a
pound in a steak restaurant,
but if I give you a
pound of cauliflower,
you will not eat it.
It's a natural thing.
I've done it.
I've been at home-- here,
a pound of cauliflower.
And they ate one
floret, and they didn't
eat any of the cauliflower.
But I gave them a
pound, to everybody.
I took it, then I
took a pound of steak.
I put it.
I had to do more steaks.
[LAUGHTER]
This is my kind of research,
which I know is not empirical,
but this is my type of
research-- unbelievable.
So we have to do something.
We need to bottle-- I
mean, maybe that is true
that are aliens, that
they already kind of put
in our brains so they were
able to infiltrate our DNA back
when Adam and Eve were created.
CHRIS YING: Mm-hm, sure.
JOSE ANDRES: And now we are
really, really all getting fat.
And the obesity pandemic
is just an alien strategy,
really-- we've seen
movies-- to get
us so very fat so when they come
to recollect, because we are
like a flock of people-- it
has to do with Hannibal--
we will be big enough that
they can take the proteins back
to their galaxy.
[LAUGHTER]
So, I mean it.
And McDonald's is not really
a corporation from America.
It was created by aliens.
So we are all getting fatter
and fatter and fatter.
And they give you food so cheap.
Why?
Because if they would, they
will give it to you for free.
But then we'll be seeing
as maybe it's the aliens.
CHRIS YING: Suspicious.
JOSE ANDRES: Because
why they will
give anybody food for free?
Because they want us fat.
[LAUGHTER]
Now going in a serious way--
and it's food for thought--
vegetables need help.
And I could do a burger
place, but everybody
has a burger place.
I could to a burrito place.
[SCOFFS] Everybody
has a burrito place.
Now it's the salad gardens
that are happening.
But I thought, let me do
the most difficult challenge
and one that I don't have
competition-- vegetables.
So I created a restaurant.
Can you put me the
video of the vegetables?
Why is "Hannibal"
still-- And I created
a concept called Beefsteak.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And I created vegetables
that misbehave.
They're not vegetarian.
They're not vegan.
They are cool and sexy
and fun and naughty.
-Uh-oh.
[GASPS]
JOSE ANDRES: Great.
[ROARING]
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Hey!
JOSE ANDRES: Oh, yeah.
Why?
Because tomatoes go
to the jacuzzi naked.
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
"Beefsteak"--
Vegetables, Unleashed.
Why?
Because we need to do that.
Somebody has to.
Because I do believe--
I love vegetables.
I do believe it's the right
way to be moving forward.
Meat consumption is
not going to happen.
I'm going to die before
everything is a mess,
but at the level, at
the rate of production,
every time we eat
a steak, I don't
know how many acres of trees
are being cut in Brazil,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So I did the concept
that my company says--
and you need to live
by your beliefs-- we
want to change the world
through the power of food.
And this is
pretentious like hell.
I only have 21 restaurants.
How am I going to
change the world
through the power of food?
I wish I did it before, but
I was not ready until now.
But I do believe that
a concept like this
can change the world
through the power of food.
I have one.
I have four more in there
for this year coming.
We're hoping to do 10 next year.
We're already gathering
the troops way ahead.
If I'm going to crash,
I'm going to crash quick
so I don't notice
the pain of failing.
But I don't want to go
any slower, because we
don't have time to go slower.
So you come to see-- can you
find that photo on Google
of Beefsteak?
Put "Beefsteak Jose
Andres" or something.
And I did the bowl of vegetables
that you boil in front of you.
We cook in front of you.
We put sauce.
We put toppings.
We put eggs.
We put avocado.
I even have some chicken.
Yeah, any one.
Chris Martin already came three
times, MC Hammer six times.
[LAUGHTER]
MC Hammer is going to be one of
my partners, Gwennie Paltrow.
But then every day,
we have lines outside.
Look at-- and I went blue.
You know why I went blue?
Because I did a study on all
the fast food, and the blue
was not taken as a color.
Everybody's red, everybody's
yellow, everybody's green.
Blue is totally uncovered.
And then in my pre-K school,
my daughter's school, pre-K,
during five years
every September,
I will be there,
after the first year,
because they did a voting
of their favorite color.
And for five years straight
by a margin of 55%-- and this
is not polling.
This is real data.
Polling is so yesterday.
[LAUGHTER]
55% or more of every
year, the pre-K children
voted on blue their
favorite color.
Who are going to be
my future customers?
These pre-K boys and girls.
Why I believe blue is the color?
I just told you.
So it's very empirical.
I did really not blue,
because my eyes are blue,
which they are.
That's why my wife
fell in love with me.
But we did the blue.
And this is, ladies and
gentlemen-- take a photo.
That's what we are
when you arrive.
It's vegetables and toppings.
And you choose.
And I have no menu.
Menu is making us stupid.
I want a number five.
What is in the number five?
I don't know, but
I like the number.
Fuck it, no.
[LAUGHTER]
Now people talk to each other.
This lady that came
from McDonald's told me,
I learned more in a week
here than ten years working
in McDonald's.
Besides, I pay $3
or $4 more per hour.
She learned how to chop.
She learned how to look.
She told tell me, I love to look
at the white boys in the eyes,
she told me.
I never thought about that.
Because they are all
the time like this.
She comes from another
part of town where I am.
All of a sudden, I
see that this is not
about the vegetable concept.
It's so much bigger.
We have already three
roofs on the top
where we're going to be
doing a little farming.
So 2.5% of the vegetables
will come from the roof.
And I'm trying to convince
somebody, maybe Google, maybe
Disney, to do a vertical tower,
where 25% of the vegetables
can come from the
restaurant above.
That will be a dream.
That will be real local.
Did I answer?
CHRIS YING: What is
exciting as a cook,
as an eater about
vegetables, too?
What do you love
about vegetables?
I mean, I understand--
JOSE ANDRES: How
many of you eat meat?
OK, you put the piece
of meat in your mouth.
What happens the first seconds?
Besides you cannot talk.
All the juices are all over.
And you are like, man,
I'm a lion, a lioness.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
What happens during
the next 45 seconds?
[LAUGHTER]
I want you to do
one thing next time.
You just bite into
the meat five seconds.
When it's finished, take it.
Don't look at it.
And then put it back again.
It's the worst experience
in the history of mankind.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like zombie wars
as a main course.
It's terrible.
On the other hand, a vegetable
doesn't have the peak of flavor
like meat gives us, but it has a
very amazing melody through it.
And when you are able to eat
through entire melody instead
of a horror movie,
Alfred Hitchcock going up
in the stairs there, and
you're standing, you know?
Anyway, it's a very
different experience.
And obviously, vegetables
for many, many reasons
are the way to go forward.
And I'm not going to be
here annoying everybody
with the data of the why.
But that's why I did the
more challenging concept
I could do to do my
billion dollar, my unicorn.
Which now I'm sad, because now
I discovered that there's also
a unicorn and dedracorn,
that your company's worth $10
billion.
So I'm like, fuck.
[LAUGHTER]
I just learned about unicorns,
and now it's a dedracorn?
Which is a $10 billion
valuation in matter of-- yes?
I do believe this
company can be worth.
But if it's not worth
it, the best scenario
is that it will serve
as a good mechanism
to ignite more people to keep
trying those restaurants.
Because we need more
of those restaurants.
Do you want a clown
to feed the world?
Or you want a chef that
tells you a joke or two,
but we're serious about
the project of doing it.
I rather prefer to have chefs
filling the world, not just
corporations.
I have no problem.
I want to have a
corporation, too.
But at the top of
my corporation is
going to be changing the world
through the power of food.
And that will go hand
by hand of the failure
or success of the project.
CHRIS YING: I have
more questions,
but I think that we
should probably open it up
for other people.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
My question is around how I've
observed many chefs as they
become more and more
capable themselves
have a linear progression
of their time and the value
they provide society until they
start to separate themselves
from the hands-on aspect of
the day-to-day activities
of the restaurant.
Where they then,
through the separation,
are able to scale
their time and effort,
but then become
more distant, other
than maybe influencing, at
an executive level, the menu.
So as you attempt
to scale your time
to provide more and more
value to the world--
and thank you for
that, and it looks
like Beefsteak will be
that vehicle or at least
your main attempt to
scale your time-- how
are you intending to control
for that distance from the food?
JOSE ANDRES: The answer
is people, people, people.
I mean, I read a little bit
how Google is organized,
but organizational
charts are going
to be key for future success.
And I mean, my first-- I
went to the World Bank,
and I gave this kind of
stupid thing of how I do it.
Nobody in my company believes
me, but that's how we do it.
But many organizations are
pyramidally organized, right?
There's a moron at the very
top sometimes, like me,
that sometimes you wonder
how you made it there.
And then you have
people under, the CFOs
and those stupid titles
we give to each other
to feel powerful, and the CMOs.
My CMO is here.
[LAUGHTER]
And interns-- there's a lot of
interns here, right, I hear.
I have interns, too.
White House used to
have a lot of interns.
[LAUGHTER]
And then what happens,
I am at the top, right?
Like at Starbucks, probably
the CEO was thinking loud
and said, shit, I
hate cappuccino.
Somebody heard, and
then trickled down.
And everybody began
saying, shit, he said,
shit cappuccinos.
Shit, we need to take
cappuccino out of the menu, man.
And this trickles down.
The poor CEO just was
thinking loud, right?
But because he's at the
very top and there's
almost no connection,
the information,
what it does-- gravity-- woosh.
What's happening?
Oh, they've been thinking-- wow.
But the people
underneath are not
part of the thinking
in any way or form.
That's what happens.
Then when you have a good
guy coming with a new idea,
trying to change the
world, because you
are at the very bottom of the
mountain, you try to come up,
and then you have everybody
else above you with the shoe.
Come down, you moron.
It took me a long
time to be where I am.
Now you're going to come?
So it's hard to bring good
ideas, good information up.
And then when you have good
people working together,
you have people in one
side of the mountain,
in the other side
of the mountain.
So you don't see each other
and instead of uniting efforts.
Sometimes it's good to
have different things,
or you need to know that
different things are working,
maybe towards the same idea.
So everything, I do believe,
changes dramatically
in the moment you began seeing
this mountain as just a very
flat territory,
where everybody's
more able to see
each other, where
you don't have the weight
of delivering information
and ideas.
You have to work so hard,
only to deliver the idea
that at the end, you worked
so hard to communicate
the idea that the idea stops
being the important thing.
The delivery is more important.
There's one moment that you put
so much effort in the delivery,
that you are like,
[DEEP BREATH].
You give up even on the idea
because you worked so hard
in the wrong thing.
So if we start
creating companies
that minimize the
hardships of having
to communicate those
ideas-- and I'm
going through that
program in my company
right now, because I've
got a lot of new people,
and it's very interesting.
All of a sudden, I'm like,
I'm doing a restaurant.
In the old days, me?
I'm Philippe Starck.
I don't understand a
word of what he says.
He doesn't understand
a word of what I said.
We had a fucking
great restaurant.
Because I told him,
rhino, rhino, rhino.
He put me-- I don't know why--
a crocodile, a coco-drool,
an alligator.
Because in French, rhino
sounds like alligator.
I don't know what
the fuck it was.
But I wanted rhinos
in my restaurant,
and I end with alligators.
That's a true story.
[LAUGHTER]
In my meat restaurant, OK?
Talk about this bullshit.
But that was me with him.
Now I have 25 other people.
And by the time
the sign comes, I'm
like, what the fuck is this?
Well, and you have no time to
give any idea back, feedback,
because the due date for
finishing the project
is tomorrow.
What?
I was in charge of this
without anybody around me
before, not because
I was involved,
because it was my duty.
Anyway, I believe these
organizational charts
being flatter is going to key.
But then, they will need to
develop into three-dimensionals
as you keep growing.
But keep finding ways to
these different levels
of organizational chart,
that they should be flat,
really working one
with each other.
I'm not there yet,
because I'm not so big.
But I know that if I emphasize
flat organizational charts,
success is around the corner.
You got it.
We need to talk more about it.
But I believe in that.
I'm not in the middle.
I am in the middle, but
I could move freely.
I don't have to be in the
middle to feel I'm in charge.
I can go away from the
organizational chart
and still be in charge.
Actually, it's what's
happening right now.
I hire a new CEO.
She came from Ruby Tuesday's,
$1.5 billion company.
She's far away, 10
times, where I am.
She's going to be helping
me move in my ideas.
And I'm moving myself out
of the organizational chart.
But still I'm in charge.
Or at least, that's
what I like to believe.
So I hope this
answered your question.
But I believe these flat
organizational charts
are going to be key to
help me achieve everything
I'm doing-- movies, a
new series, my TV show.
And still I didn't mention your
restaurant, my work in Haiti
with Clean Cookstoves,
my work in LA
that we opened a kitchen
that's going to be
feeding 25,000 people a day.
We opened it just-- we did
the first part yesterday.
I'm going to Harvard
to teach in the fall,
coming here to share my
crazy ideas with you.
If I believe in this platform,
I'll be able, as a chef,
to keep delivering
in all those levels.
Because I cannot
focus on one thing.
My brain doesn't
allow me to do that.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about Beefsteak.
From the vegetables
that you found in the US
that are not so
common in Spain, which
ones you found more
surprising, like okra
or all these things that
are not so common in Spain
but are common here?
And also, which vegetables
that are common in Spain
you miss the most here?
JOSE ANDRES: OK so
my most amazing thing
is when my daughter
Carlotta comes to me
and like, Daddy, today we
went to the Potomac Park,
and we went to-- oh, what's
the name of the path?
Oh, shit, it has
a very funny name.
The Billy Goat Trail!
Man, you people are
powerful at Google.
You know everything
here at Google, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And that's why it's
so cool to be here.
Like, look at you.
You surprise me.
How the fuck you know
about the Billy Goat Trail?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, the Billy Goat Trail
is the coolest trail
in the history of
mankind-- the coolest!
Let me go back a few
centuries before.
Lewis and Clark--
OK, let me see how
I unite the Billy Goat Trail
with the Lewis and Clark
bullshit.
Because I'm trying
to create momentum.
The National Archives-- you've
been to the National Archives?
The coolest institution,
all the great documents
of the history of America, yeah?
The archivist-- for two
years I was at the board
of the National Archives.
Don't tell me how.
Everybody was a Kennedy, a
Rockefeller, and then Andres.
I didn't fit there, believe me.
I went to the
meetings like this,
and everybody-- anyway,
their archivist emails me.
Like, urgent, urgent,
meet me at the door
of the National Archives.
I'm like, what the fuck?
What happened?
What I've done wrong?
I didn't take the
Bill of Rights.
I didn't!
I thought about
it, but I didn't.
I go, and he brings me a paper.
Are you with me?
Billy Goat Trail, but I'm--
Lewis and Clark to-- yeah?
And he brings me a document.
And the document
is a peace treaty
between the United
States of America
and the Indian tribes
of what is now Illinois.
And somewhere in the treaty,
they agree about giving
an orchard-- an orchard,
like a fruit farm, yeah?--
of something called pawpaw.
Pawpaw was what gave the
opportunity to Lewis and Clark
to really make it back
to the East on time
before the cold
weather hit, and they
will be suffering and maybe
die before they make it
back to the East.
And they did it because
they ate pawpaws.
What is the pawpaw
and what does it
have to do with the
Billy Goat Trail?
Because my daughter
comes to me and tells me,
Daddy, I found a pawpaw
at the Billy Goat Trail.
Pawpaw, which in some
cultures is a papaya?
No, that is not papaya.
It's the ultimate, most
iconic American fruit.
All of a sudden,
I don't know, that
became for me-- I
bought 100 trees.
I gave it to farmer
friends of mine.
They are still growing.
But pawpaws are the
American fruit that America
doesn't have a clue about.
And I'm in love with them.
And it's an amazing fruit.
And I learned it
through my daughter,
which I was about to smash her.
You don't have a clue,
cannot be pawpaws.
Daddy.
My surprise, when she takes
me to the Billy Goat Trail,
in the middle of the forest,
I found the pawpaw tree.
It was fascinating.
That's one of my
most amazing ones.
And when I play
golf, that finally
I understood why to have a hat.
Especially if you
play in West Virginia.
I have a very expertise of
putting the ball in the forest.
And this should be an
algorithm about it,
because when I go
towards the forest,
the ball ends in the forest.
But when I go
toward the fairway,
the ball ends in the forest.
[LAUGHTER]
I thought, if I go
towards the forest,
the ball will end
in the fairway.
Always it's in the forest.
And the hat has had to do.
Mentally, we're connected.
I go in the forest, and what
do I find, in the right moment
in the right season,
which is now?
Morels!
And I grab my hat.
I fill it with the
morels, and fuck golf!
[LAUGHTER]
So, and then I'm from Spain.
Every day that
means less and less.
I'm going to Spain next
week, because there's
a friend that with
Anthony Bourdain
they're doing a
book about Spain.
Matt Goulding, he has a blog
called Kingdoms and Roads.
If you like food and you
want to follow the best web
blog, the best writers ever,
besides Lucky Peach-- but you
are amazing.
CHRIS YING: [LAUGHS]
JOSE ANDRES: He
doesn't have magazine.
I love him.
And I'm going with him.
I need to bring
you, too, and then.
CHRIS YING: Yeah, fair
enough, fair enough.
JOSE ANDRES: But
you are amazing.
CHRIS YING: Roads and
Kingdoms is great.
JOSE ANDRES: Roads and Kingdoms.
Kingdoms and Roads?
CHRIS YING: Roads and Kingdoms.
JOSE ANDRES: You know Matt.
So I'm going with him.
And what I love is percebes.
Percebes is gooseneck
barnacle, which
has the biggest reproduction
piece of equipment
in the animal world.
[LAUGHTER]
It's 250 times its size.
I mean, it's really powerful.
In sex terms, it's
very powerful.
Those are gooseneck barnacles.
And I love them because
I'm a scuba diver, myself.
[LAUGHTER]
It's true.
Are you-- you don't believe me?
Who second guessed me?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, OK, to finish,
put the scuba there.
I'm going to put the
scuba diving piece.
So gooseneck barnacles, the
best ones, as the sea urchin,
are roughly at 10
meters under the water.
Because that is where you
have the laminaria, which
is a type of seaweed, which is
the tastiest of the seaweed.
The seaweeds you find at
one, two, three, four meters
are not as tasty as
the ones that you
find between roughly 8 and 12.
So the percebes, the gooseneck
barnacles, coming from here--
but they don't eat the
seaweed themselves,
but all the microcosms of
food use around that is great.
The sea urchin, the best
ones come from 5 to 10 meters
underneath.
The sea urchin on the
water level are no good.
You go to Hokkaido, the
good ones, 5 to 10 meters.
The ones at the sea
level, not as tasty.
That's how picky I am.
Look at the scuba diving.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
On how a chef also
can be helping.
You know that problem
with lionfish, right?
It's a huge problem.
The lionfish has
nothing to do, people.
People, we have
everything to do.
So now, they are doing these
championships in the Caribbean
that you get a group
of friends, and it's
hundreds, thousands of people.
And you go into the
ocean to see who
can catch more lionfish
in two, three, four hours.
And it's like the best
competition in the history.
I've never done the
competition, but I'm
getting ready to be the
Jacques Cousteau of lionfish.
[LAUGHTER]
Look at it.
I love that one.
I love the-- I mean,
I never thought
I will be hunting
for fish, because I
like to be with the
fish and talk to them.
But this is actually
unfortunately
a thing we need because they are
killing every single creature
in the Caribbean.
That was me missing, yeah.
What the heck?
Look at these thick [INAUDIBLE].
You talk about technology.
Sometimes, technology is
what I'm showing you--
a very simple,
recyclable water basket,
water whatever you
call in English,
transformed with this funnel
into the best lionfish holder
in the history of mankind.
I love these.
Sometimes technology
doesn't have
to be the biggest prototype
ever created by NASA.
Something simple as that
can be changing the way
we are protecting the oceans.
You got a recipe
or two to do today?
Make this salmon
dish at home, please.
I highly recommend it.
It always works.
[LAUGHTER]
And I hope to see you
soon in Washington,
DC, or anywhere else our--
[LAUGHS] Billy Goat Trail,
man. [LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
Good night.